hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to 903 m now this is
actually an interesting game because
it's a charity game based on the events
of the tsunami that happened in Japan
back in 2011 this game is two bucks on
Steam and half of the cost goes to
recouping the development cost in half
of it goes to charity to help children
who lost their parents in the tsunami
back then and after the development cost
have been recouped all of the
contributions or all of the revenue from
this game goes towards the charity and I
think this is actually an important
message because as you all know or most
of you should know the recent tsunami in
the Philippines was devastating like uh
turley devastating to that population
and an exorbitant lehigh number of
citizens and all around the world live
in areas that can be affected by
tsunamis and it's just kind of
ridiculous the impact that it can have
when nature throws a curveball like this
I mean there always are things that you
know we do to prevent it from happening
but I mean it just can happen in and
like in like in New Orleans when I'm
back in o6r I'm not I don't go beyond
that I don't know the exact date but
like things can happen and just utter
devastation over what we assume to be a
safe location so this game is in
dedication to the Japanese efforts but
remember that this stuff can happen all
over the world so be mindful of the
situations in to people all across the
globe so anyway I'm gonna play this it's
gonna be very calm playthrough it's not
going to be any loud voices or loud
yelling um from the reviews that I saw
this is an utterly beautiful game
for only $2 in I don't imagine that it's
very long I may not even play to the end
but it's it's a game about exploration
of finding items that were left in what
a beach on San Francisco from debris
from Japan no I actually don't know if
that actually happened but I mean it's a
possibility but anyway let's get to it
from what I read the objective is to
find the butterflies and right now I can
tell that the music is just beautiful I
should probably say this isn't a horror
game in any way this is enough fine the
butterflies here there you go if this is
just an elaborate setup to jump-scare
you this is exactly what this game is
and the rather beautiful setting right
now very stylized in the game of fry
this is a girl I know this is probably
the most droll and dry thing I've ever
done but see I can't even sprint I don't
see any butterflies right now but just
be just keep in mind the message of it
because some games like this are
important in and this specifically
because it's actually ingrained in
reality and and has a basis for what
actually happened in the world and is
that a butterfly glowing more than
anything else no oh oh wow
move the mouse across the edge of the
screen to rotate the item find the clue
and click 'add there's a butterfly oh I
see so it's kind of how to use Sato I
wouldn't be surprised if that's a print
it said that's the name of a real victim
of the tsunami
can I just say that this game is
gorgeous in a lot of ways oh man it's
beautiful it's honestly beautiful anyway
it seems like the butterflies are more
of like a metaphor find the butterflies
on the objects that glowy thing is
actually a trail I just noticed that led
me to the next person I guess this is
more of a guided experience than a true
interactive game but I'm okay with that
thank you pretty cool cuz I concede of
the Golden Gate Bridge over there the
ring
nice to you hang on I see it there it is
2500 409 the 25th of April
it's really it's really somber because
you know III think of this like I'm just
playing a game but also I remember oh
that's really cool I didn't even notice
that the shoreline is receding as we get
more of these things but it's like tough
to remember that this stuff actually did
happen and these disasters do happen and
that was a wedding ring and it was just
like families to get lost in in the
tsunamis and torn apart one like parents
just died or taken like that and it's
kind of it's kind of interesting to see
a game then hexxit has an honest
emotional connection not a contrived one
or not one that is built up over a story
one that actually is true is very
touching I mean as you know a lot of you
if you don't know who I am I said my
name of the beginning but I do a lot of
charity efforts and stuff like this
actually really hits home for me I mean
I've never lost anyone in a disaster but
I've lost people before and so people
that helped me out like my friend Wade
he's lost a quite a lot of people once
again not in disasters or anything but
has the same emotional impact was that
OH
I really wonder if these were real
keepsakes that were found like on a
different Shore completely different
country
it looks like we gotta go find an old
man now so we just float off the rock
there I can't tell if that's the son of
the moon I'm gonna guess that's a moon
and this is that night but still find
beautiful I know there's some of you may
find this game boring to play but if you
play it yourself like just being here
and experiencing like the music and
stuff aids it's really cool to see
something like this and it's really cool
to see the Avenue the games can make in
the world you know they can they can
show and experience more than just
fantasy or action or something like that
they can actually portray a picture of
humanity instead of just a picture of
like when what people normally think of
when they think of games they think of
guns blazing or heart pounding action or
call of duty or halo when in reality
like gaming's can be an interactive
medium beyond what we really imagined I
mean I don't even think we've scratched
the surface on what games truly can be I
mean they started out as just you know
arcade coin fingers you know fighting
games stuff like that but um the more
you develop into the technology I mean
this isn't even that technologically
advanced I think it's made on the Unreal
Engine if I'm not mistaken but even so
like you can really show art through
gaming I believe that you know gaming is
another form of art like not many people
are probably a lot of people but some
people would disagree with me that games
aren't art just based on previous
aspects of it but I mean there really
can be if I don't know it's hard to
describe like if art can be just a
I don't know the typical definition of
art but art to me is like when something
actually impacts you and you feel an
emotional response to something
portrayed in front of you it and this is
kind of like a perfect example of what
that can be there's the third one I
honestly don't know how many butterflies
I need to find oh that's a little kids
hand
I think that was a pregnant lady and
they're standing on a crack which I
don't know if that signifies they're
standing on a fault line or something
like that
damn that was a pregnant lady Oh
I think this might be the last one I
mean I know I'm supposed to do
commentary here but I think I've said
all that I wanted to say about this game
and and what it means I mean the rest is
just kind of convincing you guys to buy
it because it is two dollars on Steam
and it's it it's just I don't know it's
hard to come up with stuff because
usually I'm I'm more energetic and I'm
usually more contrived um you know they
like stupid jokes and stuff like that
but I don't want to say any stupid jokes
about this broad because there are no
stupid jokes to be made about it it's
just you know a game can be a very
serious thing it doesn't have to be
funny it doesn't have to be super duper
amazingly out of the world extraordinary
with action and heart pumping and
everything like that
I'm just rehashing what I've said before
because I mean this game is just there
and simple it's beautiful in every way
where is the book honesty er I was gonna
think on his but teddy
I think I might have been the last one
if I'm not mistaken
um I'm not exactly sure why but just
like seeing all those people on the
beach it like it hit me like really hard
and send like a shiver down my spine
because it like I don't know why but I
mean all of a sudden I saw like all
these people and instantly I realized
what it meant was just how many people
lost their lives and you know it's out
those really this is is a really
beautiful game like seriously guys
anyway that's the end of it um is
developed by this company called space
fuzzy but anyway here the people that
made it um remember guys it's it's only
two dollars on Steam and it does go
towards charitable efforts and remember
it's not just well I mean this charity I
think only goes forth is Japanese
tsunami efforts but there's also other
things that happen all over the world
that are very important and it's it's
it's important to keep an in mind like
not just a number of people that are
affected or people or lives lost or
people that died or people kids who've
lost a branch these were actual people
all with hopes and dreams and lives and
families and people that cared about him
and when you see like that I think
that's why it was so impactful for me
when I saw them all on the beach it's
just like look at all these people that
died you know and and like how many
families are missing people and and
stuff like that you know
it's it's you know it this is an
emotional game and I really like it and
I love I love to see stuff like this you
know creative aspects to can truly bring
forward something new and all at the
same time very true to life and I'm
babbling at this point I don't know what
I'm talking about but anyway all you
guys need to know is there's a link in
the description to the game on the steam
steam store page click it if you want to
support it's only two bucks I would
highly recommend it um it's just a
beautiful experience if you want to play
for yourself so seriously give it a try
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click Dan taster for more
videos if you want
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye